bonjour j'aimerai connaitre beaumont
j'ai fondé à pitre est qu en décembre
dernier voilà c'est un fou trucks de
bâtir et américaines tout est 100 % fait
maison mon laboratoire je suis
pâtissière de métier et diplômés
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on va avoir le clic est
fourrée au nutella alors ça c'est la
grosse ventes d'app titre hug le cookie
forever des cacahuètes a aussi son petit
public le cookie classique aux pépites
de chocolat là on a le groupe i le
muffin à tout choco kefu run était là
aujourd'hui la brioche à la cannelle
nous avons là le de notes peuvent se
gonfle 3-4-3 que c'est le grâce à la vie
parce que j'ai envie d'être transparente
avec mes clients et que c'était une
petite phrase humoristique pour mes
emplacement pour savoir où retrouver le
mieux c'est monsieur sur les réseaux
sociaux parce qu'en fait c'est super
aléatoire et sinon je suis privatisable
pour les entreprises publiques et
privées et pour les particuliers
[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue dans la tuer des
titres aig c'est ici que je confectionne
tous les gâteaux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est un muffin là pour aujourd'hui
c'est une base chocolat cacao et là du
coup ils sont fournis étaient là et je
vais les décors et c'est tout mais
matières premières
poudre d'amande les noix tous les
chocolats nutella et the farine le lait
sucre glace
sucres
et sucreries voilà
la pâte à la défaite hier soir alors
opposé cette nuit et j'ai façonné du
coup ce matin et j'essaie de les cuire à
la dernière minute au plus proche de
partir pour qu'ils soient le plus frais
possible il ya chocolat chocolat c'est
le sucre
citron l'albanie
[Musique]
il y aura une édition spéciale avec des
cordes pour pour noël je vais faire
avec des nappages chocolat orange je
vais faire sucrer cannelle je vais faire
aussi le vanni il y a
je vais faire pain d'épicés des choses
comme ça vraiment pas qu'ils reflètent
noël
[Musique]